Hallo, mein Name ist Aiden. Ich bin die Tote für die Sozialität.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschwurren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Werner Haas.
Werner?
Werner.
Am Ende Er.
Genau.
Und Ihr Name ist?
Haas. Haa, doppel AS.
Okay.
Herr Haas.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre.
49.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,80 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
91 Kilo.
Herr Haas, was fühlst du uns?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe gestern viel im Garten gearbeitet.
Seit her kann ich mich fast nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich habe solche Schmerzen im unteren Rücken.
Das strahlt ins ganz rechte Bein rein.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl,
ich kann das alles gar nicht so richtig bewegen.
Und es kribbelt und die an der Außenseite vom Bein ist irgendwie alles ganz taub.
Wissen Sie, ich habe irgendwie so einen ganz schweren, dummen Kübel hochgehoben und wollte den an eine andere Stelle.
Und dann ist es mir so reingefahren.
Und ich kann also wirklich fast nichts machen und die Schmerzen sind extrem.
Die sind wirklich ganz, ganz stark.
Ja verstehe ich, Herr Haas.
Seit gestern haben Sie diese Schmerzen, oder?
Ja, dann habe ich mich heute Nacht noch rumgequält, aber jetzt habe ich es nicht mehr ausgehalten.
Herr Haas, sind die Schmerzen...
...flößlich auch wenn Sie schwere Küste gehoben haben?
Ja, ganz genau.
Ja.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen im unteren Rücken, habe ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, und strahlen aus ins ganze rechte Bein.
Also rechte Bein.
Und auch in die Po-Backe rein.
Okay.
Ja.
Sie haben auch Taubheitsgefühl in Ihrem Bein?
Ja, so an der Außenseite fühlt sich das ganz kribbelig an.
Okay.
Wo ist diese Gefühle genau in Ihrem Fuß?
Eigentlich so wie an der Seitenart von der Jeans runter.
Also seitlich am äußeren Bein entlang.
Okay Herr Haas.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie sehr stark Schmerzen haben.
Ja.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskolopon 1 bis 10?
Ein sehr leichten Schmerz und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Also ich kann mich ja wirklich kaum noch rühren.
Also die sind bei 8, würde ich sagen.
Und seit gestern, konnten Sie, konnten Sie das Bein nicht bewegen?
Oder?
Ja, ich kann das so ein bisschen bewegen, aber es ist, es tut halt unglaublich weh.
Wegen der Schmerzen.
Und haben Sie Kraftlosigkeit in Ihrem rechten Bein auch?
Ja, ich habe natürlich jetzt nicht Fußball gespielt oder so, ne?
Also ich merke es, dass das einfach alles weh tut und dass es eben so komisch gefühllos ist.
Aber Sie fühlen keine Kraftlosigkeit.
Würde ich jetzt nichts sagen, ne?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerde, Herr Hans?
Nee, das langt mir eigentlich völlig aus, was ich damit habe.
Ja.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass diese Schmerzen liegen?
Ja, ich habe natürlich versucht, ein Schmerzmedikament zu nehmen.
Vielleicht ist es damit so ein ganz klein bisschen besser geworden,
aber eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Die Schmerzen sind einfach zu heftig.
Und ich habe mich heute Nacht im Bett rumgewählt, habe alle möglichen Positionen gesucht,
habe aber nichts gefunden, wie ich es aushalten konnte.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Welche Medikamenten haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe Ibuprofen genommen.
Wie viel Medikament?
Ja, ich habe zweimal 600 genommen, aber das hat nichts geholfen.
Ja, verstehe.
Okay, Herr Hans, ich würde jetzt über Ihre allgemeine Zustand erfahren.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß oder Stufrost?
Nee.
Haben Sie Husten?
Husten? Nein, ich habe Brückenschmerzen, Frau Doktor.
Ja, verstehe ich, Herr Hans.
Aber Ihre allgemeine Zustand ist für mich auch wichtig,
deswegen frage ich mich.
Wenn ich sonst bin, bin ich ja eigentlich ganz gesund.
Weil ich habe natürlich eine chronische Erkrankung,
aber sonst habe ich keine akute Erkrankungen irgendwie.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Welche chronische Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Ich bin schon seit Kindheit Diabetika.
Seit Kindheit.
You find.
Ich habe eine Zulinpompille.
Insulinpompille.
Haben Sie irgendeine andere Erkrankungen?
Na ja, also.
Ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutchock und die Blutverdwerte
sind ein bisschen hoch.
Das ist jetzt schon vor ein paar Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Ja, mit über 45, da ist irgendwann der Spaß vorbei,
dann fängt sowas an.
Ja, nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente rein?
Ja, ja.
Ich nehme Mikadis.
Morgen im Abend und wegen der Blutfette
nehme ich Atorvastatin.
Atorvastatin und die andere Medikamente habe ich nicht.
Das ist Mikadis.
Mikadis, okay.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie dieses Medikamente ein?
Mikadis, das ist 40 zu 12,5.
Da nehme ich jeweils morgens und abends eine.
Okay, zwei mal.
Atorvastatin, in welche Dosierung?
Mit einer Abend.
Eine, in welche Dosierung nehmen Sie Atorvastatin?
Den Miligandese.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Krankungen, z.B. Infektionskrankheiten?
Nee, das nicht, aber ich hatte vor anderthalb Jahren
einen Wurstwort und jetzt habe ich einen Tinnitus,
deswegen nehme ich Tebonin.
Tebonin.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Das sind 120.
120.
Einmal.
Ich nehme mich einmal.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendein Wurstartikelkrankungen, herrhas?
Wurstartikelkrankungen, ich hoffe ja nicht.
Okay.
Herhas, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass solche Schmerzen
bisher nie gehalten haben.
Inden rücken wir das.
Haben Sie Schmerzen nicht so stark, vielleicht, aber früher auch.
Ja, seit ein paar Monaten habe ich schon,
wenn ich, wenn ich viel im Garten arbeite,
oder wenn ich auch lange am Schreibtisch gesessen habe,
dann habe ich schon auch Rücken-Schmerzen, das stimmt ja.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Aber mit so etwas wie jetzt habe ich natürlich überhaupt nicht gerechnet.
Okay.
Ja, herrhas, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, noch nie.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergie?
Ja,
also ich habe so einen Heuchstupfen, wenn die Haselnüsse blühen.
Da jetzt so im Frühling, da war ich sehr geschlagen damit.
Dann bekomme ich so Nase laufen und rote Augen und das ist ganz unangenehm.
Und dann hat man tatsächlich auch mal festgestellt,
dass ich Amoxicillin nicht vertrage.
Wie äußert diese Amoxicillin-Allergie bei Ihnen?
Da habe ich so einen Auslach bekommen an den Armen und auch am Körper.
Okay, herrhas, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft, ja klar.
Gegen Corona?
Gegen Corona, ja, ja klar.
Dreimal.
Dreimal. Okay, herrhas.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, also rauchen kann man das eigentlich fast nicht nennen,
das ist nur so Genussrauchen eigentlich.
Ich, vielleicht so zwei, drei Zigaretten am Tag,
abends zum Feierabend oder auch mal nach einem guten Mittagessen,
dann rauche ich gerne so eine Zigarette, aber ich bin eigentlich kein richtiger Raucher.
Also vor 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Also seit 15 Jahren, Rauch.
Aber nur eben diese kleinen Mengen.
Ja, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol trinke ich schon regelmäßig, so ein Gläschen Wein am Abend,
das trinke ich gerne.
Ja, kann man sagen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen, herrhas?
Ja, auch die Zahlen sind vorbei, aber ja,
als ich jung war, da habe ich ein bisschen Marihuana geraucht, aber
da ist schon lange her.
Okay.
Nur in der Jugend?
Ja, genau.
Und also auch wirklich nicht viel hin und wieder mal.
Herr Has, treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, so neben der Arbeit schaffe ich das eigentlich meistens nicht, ich sitze viel am Schreibtisch
und ne, fühlte es sich mal Fahrradfahrer oder so, aber
sonst mache ich nicht viel Sport.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von der Umf?
Ich bin Enginier.
Enginier.
Sie arbeiten im Büro, oder?
Ja.
Herr Has, jetzt würde ich über Ihre Familien erfahrt und für ihre Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Haben Ihre Eltern irgendeine Erkrankungen?
Ja, so mein Vater, da weiß ich, dass er eine künstliche Hüfte hat, aber
und meine Mutter, ja, die hat so, so, ja, das heißt Makula, die Generation, aber
das ist ja nichts, was mit mir jetzt etwas zu tun hat.
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie die Schwester?
Die Schwester habe ich nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Söhne.
Zwei Söhne.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, der eine hat so ein bisschen Sprachprobleme, der stottert, aber
das ist ja keine Krankheit eigentlich.
Aber sonst sind die gesund.
Okay, ja.
Wo sind Sie alle?
Mit Ihrer Familie?
Mit Ihrer Familie wohnen wir alle zusammen.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Has.
Ja, von meiner Seite habe ich alle die Gefahr, die ich habe.
Haben Sie Gefahr oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich wüsste jetzt tatsächlich nur gerne, was man gegen diese unglaublichen
Schmerzen machen kann.
Ja, wenn Sie diese Schmerzen ein bisschen erhalten können,
möchte ich nach der körperlichen Untersuchung
ein Schmerzmittel verabrechen,
weil diese Schmerzmittel können unsere Untersuchungen bewirken.
Aber ja, Herr Has,
vielleicht haben Sie ein Problem mit Ihrem
das kann ein Bandscheidung vorfallen sein,
aber wie ich gesagt habe, würde ich jetzt die körperlichen Untersuchungen
und dann würde ich ein Röntgenbild
verrennen lassen und ein MRT verrennen lassen.
Was ist ein MRT, genau?
MRT ist ein Bilgeber des Wertes.
Manitik Resonan Stomografie,
Ned Esman,
mit dem MRT können wir ihren Bandscheidung gut beurteilen.
Das ist eine Schmerzung,
die wir kein erstellen.
Die Körperteile werden sehr gut dargestellt
mit Hilfe dieser Untersuchung
und wir können diese Kreativität
jetzt kurzfristig umfangen.
Wir brauchen eigentlich einen Termin,
aber Sie haben sehr starke Schmerzen
und ich kann ja mit Radiologieabteilung sprechen.
Vielleicht davor können wir ein Röntgen verrennen lassen
und das wir urteilen,
aber Röntgen wäre nicht genug,
um ein Bandscheidung vorfallen zu diagnostizieren.
Warum räumt man dann überhaupt,
wenn man das sowieso nicht sehen kann?
Vielleicht können wir andere Krankheiten ausschließen.
Vielleicht können Sie gestern
Ihrem Rücken verletzen.
Das kann nicht so möglich,
aber das kann nicht so unwahrscheinlich,
aber das kann ein Fraktur sein.
Und mit tieferen Röntgen können wir ein Fraktur ausschließen.
Das klingt vernünftig.
Dann warte ich Ihre Untersuchung ab.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Geduld.
Herr Haas, Sie haben Schmerzen.
Ich verstehe.
Ich kann jetzt die körperliche Untersuchung.
Sie haben eine Frage.
Hat es nicht Ihr Gewicht in Western-Seitfall ändert?
Schön wär es.
Nein, hat es nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich habe leider ein bisschen unter Blähung.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang.
Aber sonst richtig Stuhlgang Probleme habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Danke schön.
Leiden Sie unter Handrang?
Handrang? Nein, leide ich nicht unter.
Können Sie Ihre Beine hochheben?
Oh.
Oder Ihre Füße?
Die Füße, ich glaube, das würde jetzt im Augenblick gerade nicht gehen.
Also zumindest im rechten Bein nicht.
Einfach wegen der Schmerzen.
Er hat auch das Gefühl, dass er das nicht so gut kontrollieren kann.
Als das geschieht, war es am Anfang.
Noch eine Minute, glaube ich.
Eine Minute noch.
Guten Tag, ich bin Obert Erzinger.
Ich möchte Ihnen unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Okay.
Herr Renner Haas, er ist 49 Jahre alt.
Er ist 91 kg schwer und 180 cm groß.
Der Patient stellte sich heute bei uns.
Ich habe mich seit gestern aufgetreten.
Der Patient hatte die Schmerzen beim Ausstrahlen.
Und die Schmerzen mit Parästhesie einhergegeben wurden.
Gab es einen Auslöser?
Ja, der Patient gab an, dass er gestern im Garten gearbeitet haben.
Er hatte schwere Dinge gehoben.
Danach hat er seine Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Dann sind die Sparzen aufgetreten.
Okay, gut.
Paräse wurde verneint.
Der Patient hat 660 mg Iguprofen eingenommen.
Aber die Medikamente hat nicht mehr geholfen.
Er hat die Medikamente von 1,6 mg Iguprofen eingenommen.
An vor der Erkrankung nannte der Patient ein Typ 1 Diabetes mellitus.
Arterielle Hypertomie und eine Hypalupidemie.
Außerdem leide der Patient unter Tinnitus.
Der Patient hatte bis jetzt keine Operationen.
Bei den Patienten seien Amoxicinallergie und Polynesis bekannt.
Er sei durchgeimpft.
Er nehme täglich 10 mg Atolpistatin einmal.
Er hat 40 zu 12,5 mg Mikardis und T-Boning 120 mg.
Der Patient braucht 2-3 Zigarette täglich.
Er konsumiert gelegenen Alkohol.
Er trinkt täglich ein Glas Wein, ein glässischer Wein.
Er hat in der Jugend Drogen probiert.
Er hat Mariana probiert.
Er fährt gerne Fahrrad, aber nicht vor Regeln.
Die Familienanamnese ergab eine Hypte, total endeprotese Beinfahrten.
Und eine Mokri-Generation bei Diameter.
Der Patient hat keine Geschwister.
Er hat 2 Zöne.
Er wohnt mit Familie zusammen.
Er ist ein Ingenieurin von Büro.
Er arbeitet in Büro.
Die anamnistischen Angaben durch den Amn-Ehe-Sin auf eine Diskusprolaps.
Er ist ein Anamn-Bereich.
Bei der Schmerz-Lokalisation und der Ausstrahlung der Schmerzen,
dafür sprechen,
außer wenn er leidet,
der Patient unter Parasitie.
Die Schmerzen nach einer körpalischen Belastung.
Sie sind nach einer körpalischen Belastung plöster aufgetreten.
Was wäre denn differential Diagnose?
Es kann eine Nialgie sein.
Oder ein Fraktur im
Landen-Wirguss-Oilien sein.
Was könnte die Ursache sein?
Schlimmsten.
Schwergehobene.
Was könnte denn noch eine Wirbel-Fraktur mit auslösen?
Ostaprosse.
Oder eine Metastas.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich würde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie dabei?
Ich achte auch die Schmerz-Lokalisation.
Z.B. Lezek-Seichchen.
Wenn das Patient gehohren ist,
dann würde ich erst eine Röntgen verlassen.
Wie ist die Frage?
Die Frage ist, ob ich die Anhebe habe.
Was soll die Röntgenaufnahme für eine Aussage bringen?
Ich trage sie natürlich.
Ich habe sie auch.
Was soll die Röntgenaufnahme für eine Aussage bringen?
Ich trage sie natürlich.
Nein.
Warum machen Sie eine Röntgen der LWS?
Ich würde eine Fraktur auslösen.
Das ist die Frage.
Das meinte ich.
Die nächste Untersuchung wäre eine MRT.
Die MRT ist diagnostisch.
Wie würde es therapeutisch weitergehen, wenn sich Ihre Verdachtdiagnose bestätigt?
Wenn das Patient ein Traum hat,
dann kann er die Patientin konservativ behandeln.
Das wäre eine Schmerz- und Physiotherapie.
Wenn es nötig wäre,
sollten wir eine Operation durchführen.
Welche Medikamente würden Sie geben?
Schmerz-Mittel.
Alles ist gut.
Es gibt noch ein Verfahren zur Schmerz-Reduktion?
Natürlich.
Das ist eine Lokale.
Die Lokale wäre unter CT-Kontrolle.
Das ist die Portisol-Einspritzung.
Sie bleiben nichts schuldig.
Hier sind noch zwei Fragen von den Kufern gestellt worden.
Nachdem der Patient geschildert hat.
Das ist ein berühmter Nerf.
Jeder der Rückenschmerzen selber kennt und sagt,
dass es nicht so schlecht ist.
Wenn die Leute hören, die von Rückenschmerzen geplagt sind,
dann sagen sie auch selber,
dass es nicht so schlecht ist.
Im Gesäß hat der Patient auch Schmerzen.
Wenn man nachdenkt,
dann muss man in diesem Fall den Primarius suchen.
Das ist ein Mann.
Der Patient hat keine Bescheid, aber vielleicht Lunge.
Ich kann alles glauben, aber nicht, dass das ihre erste Anamnese ist.
Die war so gut wie perfekt.
Ich habe mich sehr sicher unterwegs.
Haben Sie schon oft zugehört?
Haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Das ist ein bisschen interessanter.
Leiden Sie unter,
haben Sie bemerkt, dass man nicht immer die gleiche Standardformulierung hat.
Das war eine sehr schöne Anamnese.